alors j'entends me sens on va parler de
votre livre est comme on me dit que vous
appelez aussi jean lefebvre on va faire
un test d'identité je serai plus
tranquille quand même votre vrai nom
c'est jean lefebvre ou jean d'ormesson
gens brûlent ou la lumière france là
paul lefèvre d'hommes budget non dit
jean d'ormesson on va voir si c'est bien
vous quand même votre numéro à
l'académie française c'est combien
12 arrêts 12 7 remplaçants alors
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on dit un ou une pétale de
fleur a bien qu est ce qu une tape il
ose
une tapineuse non
c'est laurent s'est abîmé dans la nuit
qui sont en train de voler le boulot la
ccct ne tapine aux genres ne tapine aux
cesca trappe une tapineuse
c'est une figure de style exprimant de
manière satirique une idée péjorative
bravo qu'est ce qu'une anacoluthe il ya
un acolyte c'est une rupture
c'est une discontinuité dans la cause
qui lui tient en une phrase c'est le
brûlant raison
je fais un nyctalope anita le qui voit
la nuit à boire aux gens
alors qu'est ce qu'une marie [ __ ] il
marie salles après qu'il a une forme de
bateau bien un bateau à fond plat un
bassin
alors là
attention aux faux amis demandé si je
m'y connais en bateau
qu'est ce qu'une cuniculiculture hills
ça doit être quelqu'un qui cultive le
punit linguistes
[Applaudissements]
dérapage en effet
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus